minerva leyó la crítica de un libro y
predijo que el número de chicas a las
que les gustará el libro va a ser más
que el doble más que el doble de chicos
a los que les gustará que tabla muestra
información que apoye su predicción
y aquí nos muestran cuatro tablas en
cada una tenemos a cuántos niños les
gustó ya cuántas niñas les gustó el
libro vamos a ver cuál de ésta apoya la
predicción es decir queremos ver en cual
el numerito que está aquí abajo la
cantidad de niñas a quién les gustó es
más que el doble del numerito de aquí
arriba en la opción a el doble de 35 35
por 2 es igual a 70 y 40 no le gana a 70
entonces ésta no es vamos a esta opción
de acá dice que el niño son 70 niñas son
25 pues está mucho menos va a ser porque
aquí gana la cantidad de niños y
queremos que la cantidad de niñas gane y
por más del doble
vamos ahora a la opción b en la opción b
nos dice que son 80 niñas y eso hay que
compararlo contra el doble de 35 o sea
contra 70 niños y aquí si resulta que 80
le gana a 7
entonces esta de acá sería la tabla y la
tabla de dice que es la misma cantidad
de niños que de niñas entonces esta no
es por lo tanto la respuesta sería ve
muy bien vamos al siguiente problema
dice anna está jugando un juego en
inglés y tiene las siguientes fichas en
una bolsa y aquí hay varias fichas mira
dice statistics ok tomo una ficha de la
bolsa y obtuvo una s muy bien luego
regreso la ficha la bolsa si gana elige
aleatoriamente una ficha de la bolsa o
sea otra supongo cuál es la probabilidad
de que vuelva a sacar una ese okay este
problema como que tiene truco esto de
que tomo la ficha y luego la regreso
pues en realidad quiere decir que no no
hizo nada estas diez fichas son 10 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ajá
estas diez fichas siguen estando en la
bolsa y ahora tiene que sacar otra ese
para calcular la probabilidad debemos
hacer casos favorables entre casos
totales
tenemos una dos tres letras efe y por lo
tanto la probabilidad sería 3 sobre 10 y
si el problema tiene truco porque nos
dicen esto de que saca una ficha y la
regresa y eso es en realidad no hacer
nada sería una cosa totalmente distinta
así sino regresar a la ficha verdad
la regresará entonces quedarían nueve
fichas en la bolsa y quedarían solo dos
letras ese entonces en ese caso la
probabilidad sería dos novenos pero no
como si la regresa siguen siendo diez
fichas en total tres de ellas son letras
s y por lo tanto la probabilidad es tres
décimos entonces la respuesta sería c
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 19 en
el problema 19 nos dicen que la
siguiente gráfica de puntos muestra las
edades de algunos niños y la distancia a
la cual cada niño vive de la escuela muy
bien aquí no veo nada ordenado pero
vamos a ver que nos preguntan cuál es el
enunciado que mejor describe la relación
entre edad y distancia a la escuela pues
parece ser que no hay ninguna relación
pero vamos a ver qué enunciados nos dan
en el nos dicen conforme la edad aumenta
la distancia a la escuela aumenta pues
no realmente verdad están repartidos muy
muy aleatoriamente estos puntos si
quisiéramos un enunciado o una gráfica
que concuerde con el enunciado
tendríamos que tener de este lado de
este lado distancia de este lado qué
edad y conforme aumenta la edad la
distancia tiene que ir aumentando es
decir tendría que verse más o menos como
una colección de puntos así pero no lo
es verdad entonces la opción a no es
la opción b dice conforme la edad
aumenta la distancia de la escuela
disminuye tampoco esto sigue siendo muy
aleatorio para una gráfica que concuerde
con lo que dice el enunciado b
deberíamos de tener puntitos ahora
relacionados hacia abajo como algo así
más o menos sale entonces yo creo que
esta tampoco es ahorita regresamos a ver
si no estamos haciendo nada raro en la
se dice conforme a la edad aumenta la
distancia hacia la escuela permanece
constante pues tampoco eso tendría que
verse así aquí tenemos la distancia de
este lado la edad y queremos que la
distancia permanezca constante conforme
aumenta la edad o sea se vería más o
menos como una colección de puntos así
con una tendencia más horizontal en el
de acá sería una tendencia como una
línea hacia arriba y en el de acá sería
una tendencia como una línea hacia abajo
entonces hasta ahorita ninguna concuerda
y la opción de dice no existe relación
alguna entre la edad y la distancia de
la escuela pues eso suena justo a lo que
queremos los puntos están repartidos muy
aleatoriamente y yo me siento pues muy
cómodo
diciendo de esta opción entonces yo le
pondría que la respuesta es d